[Aplausos]
[Música]
transilvania es algo así como cataluña
pero con vampiros tal cual como lo oís
la tierra que vio nacer al mismísimo
conde drácula es hoy el escenario de uno
de los mayores conflictos
independentistas de toda europa
[Música]
dicho de otra forma transilvania es el
lugar perfecto para hacer un especial
halloween de visual político y si lo
sabemos hemos leído vuestros comentarios
queréis que hablemos de cataluña y
sabéis que lo vamos a hacer es más
estamos preparando la madre de todos los
vídeos se trata de una cosa tan grande
que nos está llevando meses de trabajo y
que no verá la luz hasta principios del
año 2018
mientras tanto vais a tener que esperar
pero os aseguro una cosa va a dar mucho
de qué hablar
[Música]
por el momento volvamos a transilvania
que pese a estar en mitad de rumanía
casi el 20% de su población no habla la
lengua de emil ciorán el húngaro es su
idioma materno en algunas zonas los
húngaros superan el 80% de la población
concretamente este área donde los
magiares son mayoría se conoce como
bequelin land la tierra de los de que
mis
[Música]
los que seguís visual polític desde el
principio ya sabéis que los de que lis
no están precisamente orgullosos de
pertenecer a rumanía en el primer vídeo
que publicamos en este canal ya os dimos
unas pinceladas de lo que ocurre en este
lugar que por cierto menuda diferencia
con los vídeos que hacemos ahora que hay
que hay que resaltar que transilvania es
la zona más rica de hungría depronto
hungría de rumanía ya que es un tema muy
complejo y también muy interesante que
seguramente nos dará pie para otros
vídeos lo cierto es que prácticamente
todos los años se producen
manifestaciones masivas que exigen
autonomía para esta región
manifestaciones que se celebran en las
principales ciudades transilvanos pero
también en bucarest y en budapest la
capital de hungría
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la cosa
es más compleja de lo que parece
oficialmente los de felix no quieren
tener su propio país sino simplemente
convertirse en una autonomía dentro de
la propia rumanía con unas condiciones
fiscales muy especiales que os
explicaremos más tarde así que la
pregunta es por qué esto supone
tantísimos problemas con rumanía porque
estas reivindicaciones han escalado a la
categoría de conflicto diplomático y lo
que es más importante que pinta el
gobierno de hungría en todo esto hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
con pelos en la lengua durante siglos
transilvania formaba parte del reino de
hungría por aquellos años rumanía ni
siquiera existía como país
[Aplausos]
la nobleza y las clases altas se
entendían en húngaro y el rumano era un
idioma relegado a las clases más bajas y
en muchos casos perseguido por las
propias autoridades este proceso al que
llamamos magia lización consistía en
imponer la cultura húngara a cualquier
coste
[Música]
para esas clases altas los rumanos eran
unos palurdos amigos de lo ajeno y con
un sentido un tanto discutible de la
higiene personal de hecho existe un
término en húngaro para referirse a los
rumanos lloros notebook que literalmente
significa con pelos en la lengua durante
el siglo 19 el gobierno cerró periódicos
que hablaban en rumano y hasta obligó a
muchos ciudadanos a que se cambiaran el
nombre
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas cambiaron al
terminar la primera guerra mundial el
imperio austrohúngaro perdió y una de
las cosas que te pasan cuando pierdes
una guerra es que te quitan partes de lo
que antes era tu país en el caso de los
húngaros perdieron casi la mitad de su
territorio y una de esas partes fue
transilvania y se anexionó a rumanía
de repente esos campesinos esos suelos
ni álbum ya habían estado oprimidos por
la nobleza húngara tenían el poder y
querían revancha
[Aplausos]
[Música]
así es como empezaron los primeros
intentos por parte del gobierno rumano
para acabar con la cultura húngara en
transilvania y creedme no era tarea
fácil no olvidéis que aunque este
territorio formará parte de rumanía
todavía quedaban más de un millón de
personas esos llamados sé que liz que
llevaban generaciones enteras hablando
en la lengua de istván porque ni
escritor húngaro que por cierto os
recomiendo encarecidamente pero cuando
las cosas se pusieron realmente feas fue
durante la segunda guerra mundial
hungría volvió a elegir el bando
equivocado y con la ayuda de hitler
reconquistaron sus antiguos territorios
y volvieron a dar la vuelta a las tornas
todo esto sirvió para calentar más los
ánimos de los rumano parlantes así que
en 1945 cuando los alemanes y todos sus
aliados incluidos los húngaros perdieron
la guerra rumanía volvió a recuperar
transilvania esta vez con un gobierno
comunista que tenía más ganas de
venganza que nunca os acordáis de este
vídeo en el que os hablaba de la
dictadura de nicolae ceausescu los que
lo hayáis visto ya sabéis que la rumanía
comunista fue una especie de corea del
norte a la europea uno de cada 30
rumanos pertenecían a la policía
política y no sólo se encargaban de
perseguir a aquellos que criticaban al
régimen sino que también perseguían a
aquellos que se atrevían a hablar el
húngaro de la noche a la mañana el
gobierno cerró todos sus periódicos y
les obligó a hablar en rumano incluso en
sus propias casas para que os hagáis una
idea
yo conocí a una chica de esta zona que
se llamaba y tunde es un nombre húngaro
sin embargo en su carnet de identidad
ponía joana que es otro nombre en rumano
y no tiene nada que ver con thunder es
como si te llamarás pedro y te cambiarán
a dagoberto
en otras palabras que la romanización de
ceausescu fue muy parecida a la magia
lización del siglo 19 pero al revés y en
proporciones nacho vidal yang as
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la cosa
no termina aquí en su intento por
destruir hasta el último vestigio de
cultura húngara el partido comunista
rumano obligó a miles de ciudadanos a
que se instalarán en los territorios de
mayoría húngara de esta forma los
magiares pasaron a ser una minoría en
ciudades como oradea o satu mare
básicamente toda la zona que hace
frontera con hungría pasó a ser
territorio mayoritariamente rumano sin
embargo hay una zona que consiguió
mantener sus tradiciones y su idioma esa
zona se llama shekel y la cndh
rumanía nos roba por cierto que esto tan
bonito que está sonando es la música de
alexander un grupo de rock independiente
de bulgaria que nos ha enviado su música
si os gusta encontrareis más información
en este enlace o en los enlaces de la
descripción
[Música]
en 1991 rumanía aprueba su constitución
democrática y en esta constitución se
reconoce el derecho a hablar húngaro
pero como os podéis imaginar tras
décadas de odio hacia el gobierno de
bucarest esos de que liz no se quedaron
contentos
[Música]
ahora
pero no sólo eso veréis desde el punto
de vista fiscal
rumanía es un país muy centralizado casi
todos los impuestos se cobran desde el
gobierno central que luego reparte el
dinero entre las distintas regiones
principalmente las más pobres y eso deja
en muy mala posición a transilvania que
tiene un nivel de vida mucho más alto
que otras partes del país
así es como surgió un nuevo partido
político la alianza democrática de los
húngaros de rumanía también conocido
como la de m r
[Música]
y seguro que nos sorprende si os digo
que este partido arrasa en las
elecciones en esas partes de
transilvania donde los húngaros son
mayoría y cuáles son los principios de
esta formación pues básicamente dicen
que rumanía les chupan la sangre y el
dinero aquí os suena de algo esta
historia pues esperad porque este no es
el único parecido su solución para
acabar con el expolio rumano es nada más
y nada menos que imitar el foro vasco y
navarra
literalmente
[Música]
water
y los que veáis este vídeo desde españa
ya sabéis que el país vasco y navarra
son dos comunidades con un régimen
fiscal completamente distinto al del
resto del país en esas regiones los
ciudadanos no pagan sus impuestos
directamente a madrid sino a sus
diputaciones forales una vez han
recaudado el dinero están obligados a
dar un porcentaje pactado al estado
central pero el resto lo pueden
gestionar como les parezca pues bien
esta es la solución que proponían los de
felix para su región en el año 2014
[Música]
ya que no adivina es lo que le respondió
al gobierno de bucarest exacto que es
inconstitucional la constitución de
rumanía reconoce en su artículo 1º que
son un estado soberano unitario
simplemente
[Música]
todo esto genera protestas
multitudinarias en distintas ciudades
intentos de hacer referéndums y todo
tipo de actos simbólicos donde se ondea
la bandera desde que la cndh y se canta
el himno de kelly actos que por supuesto
sientan especialmente mal entre la clase
política rumana
[Música]
el partido del gobierno en rumanía
amenaza a los autonomistas húngaro
transilvanos con la prisión las
maniobras políticas que amenacen el
orden constitucional en rumanía serán
castigadas con la prisión que como os
quedáis a estas alturas ya pensaréis que
la historia de transilvania y la de
cataluña son prácticamente idénticas
verdad pues espera porque todavía no
habéis visto nada
autonomía o anexión si alguno de
vosotros ha estado alguna vez en hungría
seguro que habrá visto a alguien
llevando una camiseta con este mapa esta
imagen representa la forma que tenía
hungría antes de perder parte de sus
territorios en la primera guerra mundial
todavía hoy en pleno siglo 21 muchos
húngaros sueñan con recuperar su antiguo
imperio entre ellos su presidente viktor
orbán
[Música]
viktor orbán es algo así como el
vladimir putin del danubio al igual que
el presidente ruso orbán es famoso por
perseguir a los periodistas que le
critican discriminar a los homosexuales
y ganar elecciones con resultados que
superan el 60 por ciento del voto además
a viktor orbán tuvo también el coraje de
promover una constitución para hungría
que reconocía el catolicismo del país
defendía al bebé al feto antes del
nacimiento e identificaba los valores
nacionales de su país algo que realmente
llama poderosamente la atención y por
supuesto como buen putt y niza a orbán
le gustaba andar no sólo en su país sino
también en los de al lado orbán apoyan
la autonomía de los sé que liz ya sé lo
que estáis pensando porque debería
inmiscuirse el gobernante de un país en
cuestiones de política doméstica de otro
en teoría lo único que buscan los de
felix es tener más autonomía pero sí
dejar de formar parte de rumanía verdad
pues lo cierto es que estos de que liz
también son ciudadanos húngaros
[Música]
hungría ofrece la ciudadanía a los
húngaros étnicos que viven en el
extranjero tal cual como lo oís todos
esos húngaros nacidos en transilvania
tienen doble pasaporte derecho a ir a
las universidades de budapest y hasta
derecho a votar en las elecciones
húngaras
esto último fue especialmente polémico a
la par que beneficioso para orbán si ya
tiene apoyo popular dentro de las
fronteras de hungría fuera de estas es
una auténtica rockstar para que os
hagáis una idea el 95% de la diáspora
húngara voto a su partido el fidesz en
las últimas elecciones legislativas un
partido que como os podéis imaginar hace
que donald trump parezca just intrusos
mientras tanto rumanía considera que
estos derechos de los de phoenix son una
violación de su soberanía en su opinión
si votas en dos selecciones a la vez no
puedes mantener tu lealtad al país en el
que vives todo esto significa que las
relaciones diplomáticas entre hungría y
rumanía son tan lamentables como útiles
para sus respectivos gobiernos por un
lado orbán utiliza a rumanía como un
antagonista perfecto para su propaganda
nacionalista y por otro lado rumanía no
pierde ninguna oportunidad para chinchar
a hungría en la política europea
[Música]
y ahora os preguntaréis y la unión
europea- qué opina al respecto pues lo
cierto es que aunque el consejo de
europa siempre ha defendido los derechos
de las minorías étnicas
bruselas no puede dejar que hungría se
apunte un tanto a fin de cuentas viktor
orbán es como el drácula el frankenstein
y el freddy krueger de los políticos
europeos así que mientras la sangre no
llegue al río ninguna institución ni
político europeo se va a pronunciar de
forma clara al respecto
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros os parece que transilvania
debería tener su propia autonomía dentro
de rumanía o tal vez no sea más que un
intento de hungría para recuperar la
influencia de sus antiguos territorios
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
conocer más a fondo lo que está
ocurriendo en rumanía el país más
corrupto de europa podéis hacer clic en
el vídeo que os vamos a poner al final
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
os deseo que paséis un halloween un día
de los muertos o un día de todos los
santos terroríficamente divertido hasta
pronto
[Música]